[موسيقى] حسنًا ، بدت صناعة الطيران كما هي مرة أخرى في السنوات الأخيرة ، يبدو أن شركات الطيران تتمتع بعصر ذهبي جديد ، حيث وصلت الأرقام القياسية إلى السماء بما يقرب من أربعة مليارات مسافر سنويًا ، ومع ذلك جاءت الربحية القياسية ، ثم بين عشية وضحاها تقريبًا جلب جائحة Cova 19 الهواء السفر إلى توقف في مايو ، انخفضت عروض TSA في الولايات المتحدة وحدها بشكل كبير مقارنة بالفترة نفسها من العام الماضي في مارس عندما بدأت محادثات الإنقاذ في الكونجرس ، ووضعها الدمار الذي يواجه صناعة الطيران في المرتبة الأولى تقريبًا لإغاثة الإنقاذ ، لكن البعض تساءل حتى ما إذا كانت الصناعة تستحق الادخار كيف يستحق أي شخص أن يتم محوه ما هو واضح مثل من نتحدث عنه ، فنحن نتحدث عن صندوق تحوط يخدم مجموعة من مكاتب الملياردير العائلية الذين يهتمون بالسماح لهم بالقضاء على من يهتم شعرت الحكومة الأمريكية بخلاف ذلك بدعم الصناعة بتمويل قدره 50 مليار دولار ، لكن هذه الأموال لن تكون كافية لحل مشكلة  أكبر
أزمة واجهتها الصناعة على الإطلاق مع عدم
وجود مسار واضح لرؤى الربحية ،
كما يقول الرؤساء التنفيذيون الرئيسيون التنفيذيون الرئيسون التنفيذيون ، ليسوا شهورًا ،
فما هي الخيارات التي تمنح
شركات الطيران السوق الأمريكية نفسها مساحة صغيرة
للاندماج
قبل الصدمة مباشرة  في الحادي عشر من سبتمبر ، كانت هناك تسع
شركات نقل رئيسية اليوم ، وكان هناك أربع شركات طيران 11 سبتمبر ،
وهو أمر لم يتوقع أحد
حدوثه حتى قبل شهرين ، كان أسوأ
كارثة اقتصادية في
تاريخ الطيران في عامي 2008 و 2009 كان لدينا
ركود اقتصادي كبير وكان ذلك  صفقة كبيرة
لشركات الطيران ورأينا مجموعة من
شركات الطيران تقرر أنه سيكون من
الأفضل الاندماج مع منافس
وتتبعها وحدها ، تتحكم الشركات الكبرى الأربع دلتا أمريكان
يونايتد وساوث ويست معًا في
حوالي 80 ٪ من جميع الأميال التي يتم قطعها في الولايات المتحدة.
يتكون السوق من
شركات طيران أصغر ، والعديد
منها منخفض التكلفة مثل JetBlue Allegiant و
Spirit Airlines ،
ولا يزال الاندماج بين الشركات الكبرى أمرًا ممكنًا ضد الاحتكار.
لقد كانت الاستعارة مواتية لهم
في الماضي ، لكن من المرجح أن تشهد نسبة 20٪ المتبقية من
السوق تغييرات أكبر ، وذلك
لتبرير رفع إجراءات الحجر الصحي
في معظم أنحاء أوروبا التي
بدأوها للتو هنا في المملكة المتحدة ،
وسيحتاج الأشخاص الوافدون من اليوم إلى  للعزل الذاتي
لمدة 14 يومًا ، فإن الطريقة التي سيعمل بها هذا
هي 48 ساعة قبل السفر ، وسيتصلون
بالإنترنت ويملئون نموذجًا
يوضح تفاصيل الاتصال الخاصة بهم والعنوان
الذي سيتم عزلهم
فيه ، ويمكن أن يكون هناك عمليات تفتيش مفاجئة في تلك
العناوين والأشخاص الذين ينتهكون
قد تواجه القواعد غرامة تصل إلى 1000 جنيه إسترليني أو
1300 دولار الآن وقد تعرضت الحكومة
للكثير من الانتقادات بشأن هذه الإجراءات ،
يقول بعض الناس إن الوقت قد فات ، وكان من الممكن
أن يكون أكثر فاعلية في وقت مبكر
من الوباء عندما كان لدى المملكة المتحدة
حالات أقل بكثير  أكثر من باقي أنحاء
العالم ، يقول البعض أيضًا إنها أداة صريحة
وواسعة جدًا وقد يكون من الأفضل
اختبارها على الأفراد ثم
عزلهم على أساس كل حالة على حدة أثناء السفر
ثانية.  يقول تور إنه سيضر بشكل كبير
بالخطوط الجوية البريطانية ، تقول إيزي جيت ورايان
إير إنهما يهددان
باتخاذ إجراءات قانونية ضد الحكومة بشأن
الحجر الصحي ، وعلى الجانب الآخر ،
هناك من يتفقون مع
الحجر الصحي بشكل عام ولكنهم يعتقدون أنه
يجب أن يكون وصول الأشخاص الأكثر صرامة
في المملكة المتحدة ، لا يزال بإمكانهم استخدام وسائل
النقل العام للوصول إلى العنوان الذي
سيقضون فيه الأيام الـ 14 المقبلة ،
وعلى الرغم من كونهم معزولين عن أنفسهم ، لا
يزال بإمكانهم الذهاب إلى المتاجر لشراء الطعام وشراء
الأدوية والأشخاص الآخرين في هذا
العنوان الذي تأويهم "  لا يزال بإمكان المسافرين
مواصلة حياتهم اليومية ، لذا
يقول البعض أن هذا لن يحتوي في الواقع على
انتشار الفيروس ، وستقوم حكومة المملكة المتحدة
بمراجعة الوضع في
الحجر الصحي كل ثلاثة أسابيع
آنا ستيوارت مطار هيثرو في لندن
، لقد غادرت المستشفى اليوم  بعد أسبوع
أنقذت فيه هيئة الخدمات الصحية الوطنية حياتي
، في الثاني عشر من أبريل ، توفي عشرة آلاف وستمائة
واثني عشر شخصًا بشكل مأساوي
في طريقها إلى أن تصبح الرجل المريض.  f
أوروبا 20.000 30.000 40.000 261 كان
هنا بعض مستشفى توماس حيث
أنقذت NHS حياة جونسون ولكن كيف
وصلت المملكة المتحدة مع أعلى
عدد من القتلى 19 kovat حتى الآن في جميع أنحاء أوروبا
ألمانيا فرنسا إيطاليا إسبانيا كانت
متقدمة طوال الأسابيع في  تجربتهم مع فيروس كورونا ،
أخبر جونسون الأمة أن
البلاد مستعدة بشكل جيد للغاية ، لكن
لم أكن أنا ولا البلد
في المستشفى في الليلة الماضية حيث أعتقد
أنه كان هناك عدد
قليل من مرضى الفيروس التاجي بالفعل
وصافحت الجميع في أوروبا  تم
إغلاق جميع الأحداث الرياضية الكبرى ولكن
ليس المملكة المتحدة ، فهذه ليست طريقة رئيسية للتصدي
لهذا الوباء ، كما
يبدو أن الحكومة لديها أجندة أخرى لاحقًا
تنكر بناء درجة معينة من
مناعة القطيع أيضًا حتى يكون المزيد من الناس
محصنين ضد هذا المرض.  حول الآن
، بدأت الحكومة في إدراك
الأخطاء التي يتم إجراؤها. دراسة علمية
تستند جزئيًا إلى إيطاليا كوف في
تسعة عشر تجربة تتنبأ بما يصل
إلى  ربع مليون شخص يمكن أن
يموتوا.استجابة جونسون بطيئة ، فنحن بحاجة
إلى أشخاص لبدء العمل من المنزل ، حيث يبلغ
عدد القتلى 71 ثم أربعة أيام
أخرى نصف خطوة أخرى ، ونخبر
الحانات ونوادي المطاعم بإغلاقها أخيرًا
بعد ثلاثة أيام أخرى يجب عليك البقاء
في  الوطن ولكن الموت يلقي بالعدوى
خلال تلك الأسابيع الثلاثة الحيوية التي تم إطلاقها بشكل صاروخي بحلول
27 مارس
عدد القتلى 1091 خبراء حكوميين
ما زالوا تحت تقدير ما سيحدث
إذا تمكنا من الحفاظ على ذلك أقل من 20.000
سنقوم بعمل جيد للغاية ولكن المملكة المتحدة لن
تتأخر  إلى التدافع الدولي
للحصول على معدات اختبار معدات الوقاية الشخصية وأجهزة التنفس ، تم إرسال
مئات من العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية من
كبار السن الذين لم يتم اختبارهم من
المستشفيات إلى دور الرعاية حيث تفشى المرض
واستمرت الجدل في الظهور
واتفقنا على أننا يجب أن نذهب في رحلة
قصيرة لمعرفة ما إذا كان بإمكاني القيادة
بأمان كبير مستشاري Johnston الذي يخالف
إرشادات الإغلاق يجب تشجيع أي شخص لا يستطيع
العمل من المنزل بنشاط
على الذهاب إلى العمل وعندما
مساء.  بدأ في تخفيف الإغلاق ،
سخر منه ممثل كوميدي مشهور
إذا كان بإمكانك العمل من المنزل ، اذهب إلى العمل ، اذهب إلى العمل ،
اذهب إلى العمل ، اذهب إلى الخارج ، لا تخرج عن
الإيمان بقدرة الحكومة على
التعامل مع السر 19 ، وهو الشيء الذي
تحتاجه للحد من العدوى  تآكلت بشدة ،
فكيف أصبحت المملكة المتحدة
رجل أوروبا المريض